Shawn Mendes and Camila Cabello made
headlines after they were spotted
packing on the PDA at Coachella and
holding hands a few days later in Los
Angeles
now a source tells E.T the two aren't
officially back together but they're
enjoying each other's company and seeing
where things go not girlfriend but very
close friend the exes were caught
chatting it up wrapping their arms
around one another and locking lips at
the music festival in Indio California
earlier this month
oh my God like we're we're kissing now
and fans quickly wondered what it all
means he's the best and I think we're
really supportive of each other and you
know always want to see each other now
ET Source explains they were having fun
and being in the moment together they
are both attracted to each other and
care about one another a lot they are
having fun I really think when you know
you know and she's been one of my best
friends since I was like 15 years old a
source previously told E.T that there is
still a connection between the two oh my
God this is a real thing adding that
they'd been in touch leading up to the
festival and have cleared the air about
their breakup we don't really put any
rules or boundaries I think the truth
about being celebrities and being in a
relationship is that it's super tricky
because there's a lot of people who want
to know more personal stuff of course
the two called it quits in 2021 after
more than two years of dating those
feelings are gonna come and I think you
just gather more and more tools to cope
with them in like healthy ways
[Music]
afterwards Camila dropped her track bom
bom which is largely believed to be
about her breakup from Sean
[Music]
and she opened up to ET about how her
new music was helping her navigate life
after heartbreak that's life you're on
the ground crying in the bathroom floor
and then you'll have feelings for
another person again and then you'll be
crying on the bathroom floor again and
that is kind of like the cycles of of
change like things just change you never
know what's around the corner now fans
speculate that Sean is inspiring her
music again after she shared this
snippet of a new song titled June Gloom
following that now viral Coachella kiss
myself
girl find out
become a culture
if you don't miss whatever if you do
honey it'll be all I think about and
while we will just have to wait and see
if Sean Mila 2.0 is a thing we're here
for the love songs
[Music]